what is happening the nation of the
rejects
aaron alexander here returning we are
going to watch
invincible episode dose today thank you
for being here
thank you for having me you are like a
young
will smith slash martin lawrence
um both of them oh i can't remember
their character names right now that
would have made this
joke so much not any better
hey listen full length watch along where
you sync up with the time code four
invincibles over at our patreon page
over there we cover so many shows with
the same tier you get the option for
reaction highlights and watch long
included for all these shows that have
thumbnails you know
patreon plugs all these reactors do them
these days and we're no exception
smash that like button i don't know why
you would do that
like the hulk yeah break your computer
and subscribe and click that
notification bell
to get notified when our next reaction
is up and gotta thank for thumb jindal
for editing these reaction highlights
for us
yeah man that's a pen
penny pennywise has nothing to do with
this
but i'm excited you gotta add value to
the videos aaron
[Laughter]
[Music]
you all thought they were better than
the rest of us
oh no what the hell
it's like blood you called me dad
what is this storyline
it comes back to this random guy this
kid oh
oh wow transition that's a whole ass
jaw oh
that's not great gross
gross that's a that's cleaner that's a
cleaner death
oh that's insensitive that's an eye man
stealthy people hmm
that was weird
[Laughter]
yeah i've thrown up in the show
i am powerless i am sandra
don't be late for school
oh my god nolan dad
sure such a unique tone who did this
we had no idea but we'll find out and
when we do they're gonna look a hell of
a lot worse than your dad right over
there
someone murdered the guardians of the
globe last night oh my god
[ __ ] what i was gonna say we're a little
understaffed in the hero department
yeah dude go do something out of anger
because your
dad is hurt oh no
oh no
oh [ __ ] oh it looks so cool
get away from those people oh my god
oh jeez
oh no no
oh cool great shot that was awesome
i almost broke my glasses
i felt it i was like oh no oh my god
i guess that is realistic
i'm really into the show i don't know
who you are but it's time
to go
these guys are the teen titans what's
going on here
i got eyes too robot is it the robot's
name
duplicate
cool oh [ __ ] duplicate
that's clever you're out of meat
adam eve i see what you did there
oh what oh
jesus so you're watching rick and morty
what the hell what triggered that
no idea weird
new to this right i just got my powers
that was my first big fight
not bad for a rookie are you kidding i
froze out there people got hurt
people escaped because of you and
everyone freezes their first time i used
to throw
up before every fight barf my guts out
that's a lot of barfing in the show i
know meet me out front after class
invincible dude you got a shot hey
you got a shot they call themselves the
flaxsense
order oxidized and corroded
for an alloy like this that should take
years
time runs faster wherever they come from
they ran off
because they were dying of old age
wasn't hiding
oh cool dark blood demon detect
damien dark blood
seven superheroes murdered help us solve
the case o
great horned homeshot
i gotta run catch you later
you joke who that is huh can you tell
who that is no who
and sassy beats had a feeling it's
aussie beasts and all these huh
from deadpool not invincible joker oh
yeah that's right
yeah dang okay okay zazzy
wow
the flying looks so cool in this show i
know they do a really great job at
drawing focus to your center character
while not blurring the backgrounds
but i don't get to move with them
oh damn it [ __ ] damn it hey
it's the iceman damn it
[Laughter]
of course it's a douchebag yeah of
course
apologies for explode rexplode
hell yes i love these names
i've created this detector to warn us if
they return invincible may we count on
you in the future
you sure you want my help he's so
insecure she already has a boyfriend
so you can be more awesome than him and
take his
great advice great friend you're so
intimidated by her
look at her
[Music]
they seem to have discovered a way to
resist our time
days three days for us decades for them
oh oh damn
the violence they do you're so good yeah
it really gets you
[Applause]
oh my too many people you guys lost over
300 people the other day
god you guys gotta you gotta improve
your numbers man
those are cool explosions
oh no no face huggers
they seem to have spent their time
wisely
save her no no
oh
keep teasing he's on the verge of eating
like his violent father right
like if someone didn't call his name he
would have murdered him oh yeah
i'll be back in a few more decades
i don't know you're stuck you're screwed
you're stuck
you're old now destroy their wristbands
i mean just aim on destroying them and
you'll probably get their wristbands
right be a lot faster
that's that's interesting i don't think
i've ever seen that in a show or
anything before
like time moving differently with aliens
i take back everything i said about you
before and i said a lot
[Laughter]
so the scariest thing i've ever seen
it sounds like tj miller but it's not
right
that definitely vibe okay [ __ ]
who is that who are all these voices
mark hey son dad ow
so he's not exactly superman all right
looks a couple tears down yeah but
basically this world's equivalent
seemingly
come on let's go home i'm dying for some
real food
you cannot console at all yeah and now
you're trying too hard
don't eat me where i am
thanks for the tip you know you have to
be able to take a hit
oh jesus
that's your kid
my god all right
let me train you you son of a [ __ ] you
want to send him to space
no i'll go okay what
why not he's not that tough mark can
take him how do i
breathe in space that's the neat thing
you don't 12 minutes
[Music]
i feel like you want this kid to die
being a dad or his racist purpose
your mood is that way is that seth rogen
i think it is
[Laughter]
why can i hear you in my head where else
do you keep your brain
i hit seth rogen here
that's what you call protecting your
planet i'm sad for your people
i fought here three years ago no i'm not
the same guy
well sucks to be you then
really you tried this already
and it works this time maybe you'll do
after all
god i want to talk
are you using your timeout
i don't even know who you are oh you
don't
i'm an evaluation officer for the
coalition
[Laughter]
your planet signed up for the program
see request from urath for evaluation
this is earth earth yes
not uraf no is that with an e
or a u e oh i'm in so much trouble
well thanks for letting me know i'm alan
by the way invincible
oh yeah little optimistic isn't it
i just bought you and i think you're
quite invincible
sorry about all that oh i made a friend
oh
you made a friend voiced by seth rogen
and alan oh he's
doctor strange
oh my god they just keep coming back
jesus the texas advanced
oh no god oh my
god i feel really bad for this alien i'm
damn you just can't catch a break
oh robot's got bad news
[Music]
oh [ __ ] oh this guy's got a vendetta for
him huh
he didn't forget oh he might be english
there he is
oh there he is
[Music]
don't first name him right superhero 101
man
[Music]
oh [ __ ] oh
get him wow
you'll never be this good mark
[Music]
oh no runner aliens
[Music]
oh yeah that's right
holy [ __ ] he went into one of their
portals oh
so he'll be late for dinner
i'd love this thing oh she's never
concerned
but taking on aliens in another
dimension
oh he's gonna do genocide
oh my god earth isn't yours to conquer
oh no oh jesus oh
no yes oh damn god
dude this looks great i love the
animation
oh yes
you monster yes oh
i mean this guy's just so cool i mean
look at him
look at this
it's fun when it's not you know our
earth right
yeah oh my god how long has he been here
oh [ __ ] oh wait they're in the time the
area
the guardians of the globe are dead
oh [ __ ] it's at the end of the episode
is that the end of the episode okay no
we still got another 20 more minutes
[Laughter]
i need the room ah crow
there's a demon man this demon man
enlighten
only guardians omni man
hellboy and constantine combined yeah
damian dark two don't leave a trace you
turn into smoke
you don't listen to it you listen and
you mention your idiotic thoughts to
anyone and i mean anybody
i'll make sure they're the last thoughts
you ever have you understand me
get out who did that to your face dude
put an asic surveillance team on the
graces
sir the killer's still out there donald
might decide to finish the job
oh what a good way that's a smart way of
lying about it
wow dude freaking do you guys have
amazon prime
that [ __ ] doesn't give you any time too
[Laughter]
you guys can't see that damn
it's good enough too damn all right so
saving dark blood is clancy brown i had
a feeling damn it should have said i was
wondering if the robot is uh
spock what the hell's his name zachary
canto yup i was right
okay i can't remember his name right uh
right off the bat zachary quinto
oh damn i feel like i really got lost in
that episode yeah like
lost within the episode not uh
i'm so succumbed by the world it's
taking me a little bit of time to adjust
to it all i don't know how it is for you
because
for me like as we talked about in the
first episode i'm like is this like a
it's some like real superhero show is it
a commentary what what is this
and then by the time i got to this
second episode i'm like well it's kind
of doing
the meta stuff and the commentary but it
really is its own show
it dawned on me when we were looking at
dark blood
of like oh hellboy and constantine
combined it's not used as just a punch
line
or something like that no it's very
genuine yeah it's it's own character
yeah we have a character who's like
constantine and hellboy
combined that's what people will think
but we're really gonna play into that
and we're just gonna make him a real
character this whole episode no we're
really laughing that much
during it there's like a couple of fun
there's like comedic characters there's
like funny characters
oh what's his name rex rexplode rex
floyd like rex explode like you have
some really funny stuff you have that
moment with todd for the most i'm like
yeah this is like a
edgy superhero show yeah it's surprising
and if seth saw in the credits seth
rogen is producing it and i know he
produces the boys and
i'm like okay so this is more tonally
akin to something kind of like the boys
in the sense of no it's
it's it's doing its thing it's being a
real show
yeah with an occasional moment of
self-awareness
i think the thing that makes it
different from the boys though the facts
that
the boys have i don't know i don't want
to say the boy is a cynical but it's
like
it has like a sense about the world
where like
yes or superheroes but they're like for
the most part all corrupt or like
there's something yeah
[ __ ] up about it but this one feels
like very much
genuine in the sense that it wants to
tell like a superhero story just that's
that's just slightly slightly tilted
slightly wrong
yes i don't know what i don't know what
commentary this [ __ ] the comic goes down
specifically when it comes to the
character of omni man
but you know it seems like it really is
a play on superman 100
you know like omni man omnipresent a
godlike figure
yeah he looks at himself like a god i
don't know if that's like the purpose of
eliminating the superheroes i'm gonna
just wait for this to find out what's up
yeah yeah no i agree i think that it's
interesting that he's
this person from a plant another planet
and his name is omni man does all the
other people
refer to themselves as omni man or omni
woman when like they're on the other
planet trying to save their planet
oh the people from his planet yeah yeah
yeah uh oh that's a good question
actually
or was that a name bestowed upon him
that is
his grand title that only he can condone
yeah i mean it seems like the show has
two plots going well now
three this has you have the
investigation of the murder with the
cecil
guy and then you have the story of mark
and then you have the story of nolan and
it seems that all three are kind of
converging where mark is
learning that yeah you're gonna do the
cliche superhero stuff finding a guy in
outer space fighting an alien invasion
but when it comes down to it the
violence is going to be a lot more
disturbing than you might have
realized that it's going to be a lot
scarier out there when you're up against
death the violence actually seems
necessary to tell
the story and for the reactions that
mark is going to have because i feel
like in a pg-13 format you just be like
come on man hurry up
you know like get to it but in a better
rated format it really puts you in the
mindset of damn being a teenager having
to deal with this
this would be a lot you know like it's
not used for shock value it's genuinely
used as part of the story to like
get home the effect of like what it's
like to be a teenager that whole scene
with
the with the grandmother like the old
lady trying to say that was
that was really messed up and like yeah
that was probably what would happen
if you should try to like duck with an
old lady
that was rough man that's a powerful
angle to go down and i love that you
start off with nolan in the first
episode as being the mentor and he is
like this villain behind the scenes he
doesn't like he's working with
anybody directly as far as we know he
might have some type of ally or
something like that or who might be
working under someone again
i feel like for some reason my mind does
go to comparing this to the boys for
some reason
uh even though i don't think it's meant
to be but just as an example how in the
boys homelander
is uh doing a lot in conjunction with
the people who produce compound v what
are they called again
i forget that but yeah i was watching
here you're like i don't he seems like
he might just be doing his own thing
you know so it's it's a little bit
confusing but what i
what i love is i do get the sense that
he loves his family
hundreds he loves his wife and i feel
like there's a this is him
i feel like he loves his son but i also
feel like he thinks there's something
that's
threatening about his son yeah like he's
like
either like afraid of what he has
potential to be or i'm
afraid the implications of him having
powers what does that mean for him
not that i want to spend forever getting
bogged down in theories but it does have
you kind of going of
he seems to be so back and forth on the
fact that his son has superpowers
yeah you know it's like he's doing the
dad role and being encouraging
and being positive it's clear nolan
cares about him but maybe
nolan has a bigger plan up his sleeve
the only one who might be able to stop
him
will be his son yeah that's kind of
where my mind's going
yeah he kind of is there times where it
really seems like he's threatened by him
watching this episode made me really
kind of dread the moment
where we're gonna have to see them
fighting like instead he finds out what
his dad is doing like that to go
head-to-head
again i have no idea what happens in the
comic books or like even if this is
accurate to the comics but i know that
for what they're setting up now between
the father and son relationship
and the the complexity that is bad union
or
that that dynamic it's going to be
really
really tragic and really sad when things
come to a head
and i'm wondering too about uh his whole
high school life there's
there's parts about the high school
later that i wish were because sometimes
the show i i can't
like it's only the second episode yeah
so there's times where i'm like i can't
tell when the show
might be a little bit at odds with
itself in terms of the world that's
inhabiting
um i feel like it's genuinely like such
a pretentious douchebag
where's
[Laughter]
the show invincible
what i mean by that is it sometimes goes
out of its way to
be like this is a show that yes we're
embodied in
this an animated superhero world when it
comes down to
consequences and violence we're gonna
show
what some of the realistic effects that
can be
for our characters yeah you know what i
mean yeah like that's a quality about
this that i really love it deals a lot
with consequences
and the the decisions that we make the
sacrifices we have to deal with and i
love that it's like oh you have this
beautiful like
almost kids like animated format like
the way the animation looks but then
then you finally you see it's like a
real mature adult show and then you got
the high school element to me though
that doesn't seem to give two shits
about being all that realistic
so that's part of where i get a little
bit pulled out
when it comes to mark is i wish that
they were making a bit more of an effort
to make him feel like
like he really has to deal with being in
high school kind of like with like a
peter parker story to a certain extent
yeah of like what it must really be like
to be in high school
while being a superhero and dealing with
this and i feel like that would just add
more weight
yeah they're focusing very much on the
romantic aspect of what it's like to be
a superhero in high school to that i can
say it does remind me
a little bit of this fantastic show that
you should definitely check out called
the spectacular spider-man
it came out from 2008-2009 uh it was it
was just a very
stupid
bunch of video essays really dumb
man yeah talking about the [ __ ]
spiderman let me talk to high top
films first the end-all be-all expert of
spider-man
in that regard it's very it comes across
very genuine in the
both the the home life of of mark and as
well as like setting up his establishing
characters that are both his um
contemporaries as far as the high school
aspect together
with um what's it was his best friend's
name do you remember
uh white boy
like not a character yeah he's just his
supporting best friend i'm in high
school with you man
then i'll talk to you outside of here
right and then uh with uh
with the girl who he saved in the first
episode who like got
amber yeah and amber uh who's as he
beats us playing she seems like
something that's going to be
important going forward within yeah the
context of
of what's going on with the mark i feel
like they're there's kind of teasing a
little bit with like the alice the alice
even mark things maybe
like a love triangle thing oh yeah i
mean like that that part to me
was fun because this keeps it on the
superhero focused angle when it comes
down to it
that's just a nitpick it's not an actual
thing where i'm watching it going i
wish the show it's we're just
i love that the family life is uh and
everything i say now is gonna sound like
i'm just trying to like
make that point hit when really no i'm
just moving past it like the family life
i love how lived in that feels
it's funny yeah how the wife is not
distressed at all
okay very casual yeah about it yeah yeah
like it's funny
but it feels lifted yeah this is kind of
what i imagine their lifestyle might be
like
at a certain point yeah that makes a lot
of sense yeah with him in
in high school it's like yeah i like the
eve stuff keeps dealing with like the
reoccurring thing of todd just keeps
coming to him in the hallway to bully
him
you know like that's all fun i want to
see a little more of his friendship life
yeah he doesn't seem like he has like he
has his best friend who is talking about
the school
you're right i guess i guess versus
friendships you know it does feel a
little
uh unbalanced in that way maybe we'll
get more of that in the future
one thing i don't think we talked about
in the first episode which i really
appreciate is the fact that this is the
only animated show at least i've seen
where it is 45 minutes long
yeah so it really gives that's great a
lot of the stuff to breathe because we
do have that space
in animated form we may actually get
that
more more of his high school dynamics
more of stuff between him and his friend
him and the love interests or maybe just
seeing how he balances being a superhero
and a student i mean that'd be fun i
don't think the show will go then
at the end of the day i don't know why i
don't know why i freed up so much i'm
like i'm looking for something when i'm
like
to be honest i'm not even like watching
it going i wish we could get back to
that
more interesting when you go to the
planet you've encountered the seth rogen
character and expanding out the galaxy
in that way like that's all the really
cool stuff to deal with
yeah i think i think maybe in the
in the future we'll probably get less
and less away from high school stuff and
more into like
the nitty-gritty of like the cool stuff
seems like that's where we're going
right away
yeah yeah i like wasting any time i like
that i love too how
in this world that's already developed
that they they not only have a justice
league they already had their like
lower tier teams as well they got their
doomed patrols they got their
they got their team titans fight force
yeah
they got their lower tier teams i love
all those lived-in aspects
of he goes to school i mean he goes he
he starts working amongst one of the
lower ring teams like yeah that's kind
of where mark status would lead him is
to this kind of team
right you know he wouldn't immediately
graduate to the guardians you would have
to be around here and also the mystery
too and the angle of them hunting down
nolan is a quality to this that i love
that has such
such wonderful tension to it yeah like
when he is
when it's obvious cecil is very
suspicious of nolan
that nolan is probably the one
responsible for all this and has to work
with the demon
like that's all great i i love having
this um mysterious angle to it yeah and
i think it provides something unique
in the way that it is both a mystery to
the characters in the show as to what
happened
but we saw what happened yeah we still
don't know why it happened so it's like
a double mystery going on also shout out
to the woman
eve i thought was a great character um i
thought she has there's a lot of life to
her
and that's a that's a character that
could have easily been bland
or like i've seen this character a
gazillion times and i can't quite put my
finger on it right now
maybe because we're shooting this so
damn late can you stop doing that for
some of these tv shows
but at the moment i found myself very
early on extremely charmed by the
portrayal that they have
bestowed upon us with her so yeah so far
damn good show really enjoying the hell
out of it glad you could be here aaron
guys
what do you think about this show leave
your thoughts down below subscribe click
that notification bell hit that like
button
last but not least
michael b omnimedia wanted to shout him
out because
this guy is killing it on youtube lately
first person to get up the snyder cut
reactions he's doing all kinds of
reactions on youtube
he's covering invincible as well and
more importantly he's just been an
amazing friend
a great guy who talked to each other
periodically
actually usually like once a week at
this point love chatting with him i'm
also really jealous of him
i found out that so much you know what i
probably shouldn't say it
[Laughter]
i caught i caught myself i shouldn't i
shouldn't
i shouldn't ratchet up okay okay
not in front of them it's not even
ratting you out it makes it sound like
you're doing something wrong
they make all of them want to know what
he did i'm just saying like you know
like there's
this side of this you know like
i'm just saying okay i just don't want
to put any eyes
a target on your back here i mean
they're not you have anything wrong it's
you know it's just we get targeted for
certain stuff on this channel
and i see that you don't
[Music]
he's fine you know you just don't deal
with it as much as us
right you know what i'm talking about he
knows he knows
i don't know you have no idea damn it's
too bad it's okay
they know so happy i just don't want to
say it and then certain companies to be
like oh damn you know what maybe we'll
lock on to them oh [ __ ] yeah you need to
watch yourself watch your back
yeah yeah hopefully you say it's about a
few other friends of mine
great guys you're back he's not gonna
write you out yeah yeah
stay alive brother stay alive thanks
give it up